hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within hi
kitty
oh don't worry it's only a bunch of
shifting bodies not much to worry about
it all I'm done saving for now but there
was another thing on the desk here that
I drew but see no idea what he's done
does he it's not surprising that he
doesn't care he was never motivated by
fear of mobius hmm the stem prototype
works but only when connected to Ruben
hmm I've checked the shields and he
customized the whole system to only
operate with his own brainwave pattern I
left him alone with the device for far
too long
trusted him too much and despite all my
knowledge in the fields past the point
of fixing I can't just flip a switch hmm
and that's not the worst of it they know
as well I'm not going to take the blame
for this I will drag him here and make
him fix it I can't imagine what they
will do for him if he doesn't wait I
thought you did the thing to him because
you can't just flip a switch but you can
remove his brain and plug him into the
system forever and ever which is what I
was under the assumption that you had
done oh I can't imagine what they do but
maybe he wasn't the source of it all I
mean I never liked the doctor hi how's
it going yeah if you think so you had oh
that reminds me
AJ the Bell they're drawn to it good to
know where can I get a bell I mean if
this was SCP containment breach it I
doubt it
bing-bong to bring it on hello okay I'll
just slide into the middle all right
hello I'm here now hi Leslie Leslie no
all right whatever okay Wow I have to
get through this whole place things do
well I might be a little bit in trouble
all right so I just got to use my
feminine wiles oh hey there having fun
on whatever they're pulling out I hope
it's a bunch of party string red blood
colored party string also known as
sylvain hello secret passageway she's
gonna help me use this you only do
another scrap hi okay what am i little
okay back in here okay it's an exclude
you do and that's good or bad
I mean that guy might be blue okay okay
there's a bottle over here I haven't had
a bottle in a while man these guys need
to get a lot more drunk because I need a
lot more bottles to be able to handle
all this there you go buddy
whoa what is that whoa could that come
from okay
so there's got to be a way to get around
this but I don't know if there's an exit
route over there I see a fence but I
don't know if it's something that I can
jump over whoa what are you doing whoa
back away okay so it's entirely possible
there is something over here but I don't
like the way this guy's scurrying all
over the place we try a little business
huh yeah how about that
okay go oh okay isn't that the route
that I'm trying to go on damn it
how's that gonna help me at all maybe
it's not yeah I might blow up and die
from this but I'm thinking there might
be a way to get over this
nope that was wrong okay never mind
oh maybe I can kick it open oh crap oh
crap oh oh crap
well looks like I'm gonna make a run for
it oh no you didn't did you see nothing
hope you saw nothing
oh that worked out surprisingly well
that's not gonna work out well cool boy
okay wait give me that give me that okay
cool got that oh wow well I got lucky on
that one okay so I have an axe which
means that I'm am able to do something
or other okay if he goes around that
grave I'm gonna pop out what are you
doing don't look at me don't look at me
go about your business
I've got no quarrel with you except I'm
about to smash you in the skull with an
axe okay buddy
there you go yeah that's right go that
way Nellie
you gotta do we gotta do
yes that's an interesting wall why don't
you do something that's gonna help me
[ __ ] okay yes okay he's going that
way right so five whoo is he gonna yeah
that's why I keep going that way you
have no reason to turn around ever oh
you had a reason ah piss poop and piss
okay yeah yeah how about that whatever
that was
Oh grab nice burning body over there I
love the way you've decorated with this
place oh you've got such a pretty face
okay here we go okay good good good good
good good
I mean it didn't exactly destroy it I
could easily grab that out but it's icky
and gross yeah I don't want to touch it
I mean I may have blood directly in my
hair
whoa okay nice subtlety thank you very
much for that all right there is there
any secret path or something
possibly I wish the Crouch was toggle
Crouch and not individual oh here we go
got something here well I already knew
that
who's here Leslie am I here I'm not a
heat I'm a woman I'm a strong
independent woman
and did I mention that I do not need no
man okay what are you what are you doing
are you doing their sassy oh you you're
not jojo hood gonna do Rudy oh ha ha he
thought she was going to get me oh oh
you might get me who you see nothing
I'll come on how did he see that that's
a bunch of baloney
nope ah [ __ ] oh crap no no no nope ah
tips oh boy
you you lost me right somehow you lost
me okay
this ridiculous yeah yeah I'm still over
there definitely huh
damn I was only under the assumption
that the guys carrying that porches were
especially bad because they might have
been able to light me on fire and
instantly kill me that's why I fine to
get them out of the equation okay I
don't hear anyone over here so the bells
right here and somehow that's gonna help
me oh it's gonna get the people away
from the gate okay Bing bong dinner's
ready everybody come over here as I
suddenly sneak my way up nobody bother
me at all okay you ready ready
come on come on come and get it
come on little children's ain't you
proud of my children anymore okay wait
wait Oh would why why did I fall down
why I didn't want to do that oh crap how
does that help me at all
hi Leslie Leslie please open the gate
Leslie open the gate lemon now would be
great please it's safe now no this
dozens of them and explodey dudes hi
Leslie how's it going
thank you I probably could have done
that my wrists are very slender
yeah that was close here huh finally
found you
oh don't look away come on getting
stronger can't get away
we'll be fine Leslie uh shirts changed
shirts
charge charge charge charge all right
sure trigger come on stay close to me
I'll protect you sure I will I can't
even protect myself you know I remind
myself that I have exactly no bullets
okay so that's the church that's from
her past so this is all part of her life
and that's a church cetera spare her
parents were a cult in her in a cult in
the church in that Lasley damn it Leslie
Leslie you were supposed to follow close
behind well that was fun
at least I don't it Oh what how'd you
get up there okay alrighty then hi
Leslie
how's it going I can't what can i what
am i doing would what are we doing hi
hello
okay um is that really Leslie hi okay
are you are you still Leslie stop
mumbling please I think I remember from
the original game that Kidman was
escorting Leslie throughout the final
part of the game and we were trying to
chase her down also managing to clean up
the message she left behind with all the
unkilled zombies I want the big guys
around here oh this is where I'm at the
big guys uh Castellano killed the big
guys but I remember this this is toward
the end of the game as far as I remember
me just a little further it's a little
further come old as that you can do it
even though ruvik is breathing down our
neck can't you do your little mental
trick and make it all better now
okay big guys am I gonna run away from
the big guys because I definitely killed
them with Castellanos who was sad what
is that what is that oh okay great
I didn't I didn't even know that was a
thing it's being another one of the
collectibles in association with all the
other crap that I've gotten okay I don't
know where Leslie is but I'm just
assuming that he's behind oh crap hell
you've got it okay at five came a plague
taking our livestock and with that many
took their lives at seven mother turned
to the church their symbol was etched in
her mind at 14 I left leaving only a
note I wrote that I'd gone to heaven so
that's a note from kidman - oh just a
big guy what
sound big guy oh that's definitely okay
I gotta run over to that yeah running it
running now would be good Lesley you've
got a hide don't come out until I call
you wait a minute here ah a little uh
Leslie Leslie I was I I think I'm
mistaken about a few things okay here we
go
I don't know what I'm doing oh I remove
these for Castellanos then right I'm
such a good person except the dude ah
hello weeping angel statue cool it great
why do I need that why did I need that I
guess you could say I started here I
would sneak into the graveyard steal the
statues and hide them I wanted people to
think they were purchased but every
morning
the figurine has a skull for a head
appears in Kidman's nightmare it's a bad
over wait was I not supposed to pick
that up then I mean I got the real one
do I need all of them I don't know if
they're coming behind me I didn't have
enough I don't even know what I'm doing
okay that's bigger who did the big guy I
have no way to fight the big guy I
didn't even want to fight the big guy
when I was on Castellano side yeah
Leslie are you still down there
Leslie you're not even down there I was
gesturing to the air for you to go down
there I thought that would have been
clearer okay so I don't know hi oh I got
it okay so I got all of these but a boom
wait how am I supposed to know oh okay
okay I got it okay uh it was a five
fourteen seven and something else so
this is seven so this was when not the
plague but this is when they turned to
the church so it would have been here
and then the freedom is probably
represented in the wings so at five
there was the bad omen which was the
plague and then over here would be 14
when she freed herself yeah I did
Hey look at me using my brain I'm pretty
sure anyone gonna solve that but I did
it
that's impressive the church is right
ahead it should be a little safer in
there only a little bit
I didn't even see the big guy and it is
where I fought the dog right doggie
doggie wait Joe Joe is still alive right
here
you were right beside me what damn it I
I'm the little confused
hey dude come here come here come here
hey over here hey hey hey hey hey hey
hey handsome dude go over the moon I
don't like that oh my god oh Jesus
okay well I hope this keeps up no he's
as frantic oh god don't don't don't
don't don't don't don't
okay no you're stupid I got you I'm
smarter than you
you can't fit through that hole that's
obviously big enough for you oh I give
up now
well back to slamming into a boxes I get
inspiration from our fire Maddy
oh by the way I'm wearing the new
charity shirt ah they're coming by the
way anyone who's ordered to charity sure
they're being delayed not because of one
shirts faulty it's actually the
manufacturer was late on getting the
order in so we weren't able to get him
out to you guys soon enough so I've been
talking with everybody and they are on
the way out people are posting pictures
of them obviously International is gonna
take a little bit longer but thank you
guys so much for the patience and next
time we will definitely have shirts on
hand before the charity event happens
but either way it was still a successful
charity I really hope you guys enjoyed
it and I really got hope you guys enjoy
the new shirts when they get there so
and the designs really cool dude it's
really comfortable I like oh yeah this
is like really towards the end of the
game cuz it was into this chair oh no
was it wait don't get me sure Leslie
don't give me there's no bullets in that
gum gun gun gun don't get me
are you looking at don't look at me it's
alright I'm here huh nothing is going to
get you how am I gonna protect you you
have to stay with me there's no other
way Ruby hi hey buddy how's it going
what do you want with me oh you I'm just
making sure you're doing your job just
like me
I doubt they want damaged goods back up
he's coming with me oh I hope so
I needn't remind you the consequences
for failure they know our people aren't
the only ones counting on this boy you
need him to get out
oh I knew it - I knew it
we're all their pawns I knew them sure
victims they killed me they ripped me
apart and took what they needed I will
destroy what they wish to control
Rubick
stop it is my vessel I am in control
I sense a conflict of interest just what
was your mission exactly do you think
they're all prying eyes can't see in
here they've been watching you kid
okay what are you doing kid yeah you are
to bring the boy back to us no I can't
if I drink Leslie out bruva comes with
him
we don't know what he's capable of but I
can't let that happen
but what more would he possibly be
capable of in the real world I mean in
here he's God he can do whatever he
wants
pretty much to an extent but in there
swore allegiance but you are not in a
position to make decisions like this
this is not acceptable
you will bring us back welcome to the
party sir run all you want kid you can't
escape okay like everyone else that
crosses us we will hunt you down well I
didn't think I crossed you
the Slenderman coming after me oh boy
I'm running out it you have a job to do
no thank you at least now I can run
infinitely go god you're grasping hands
on your shadows it's so weird you are so
the Slenderman right now
that's so cool
stung right no thanks I'd rather keep
running if that's all right with you
okay here we go oh that's so creepy with
the shadows is so cool okay bye-bye five
five five oh god this is so slender man
he moves a static in the thing and the
grabby hands okay
I heard that from the right before it
actually got to me so I gotta listen
closely
weird okay I must be going back to the
cityscape which is where the game
actually ended because I was going to
accident
okay left left left left left left left
left left left
grabby hands no bad touch follow us why
Mobius weirdos whoa okay he'll dare you
grabby hands or bad hands I don't even
know where I get it so bring us back
that boy okay well that was the end oh
oh well I mean it's good because I got
even more DLC to play I know there's
more because I downloaded more oh that's
so cool
oh it was so well done I love that so it
was amazing it was exactly in one place
will provide us with opportunities I
can't trust you
not like this no she's she's coming with
us she's my responsibility
look said we need to talk you're getting
out of control
finally with this machine I can go back
we can continue the experiments there
are some things here that are to remain
in the dark beacon I just hope I can get
there before he does
a little hasty with that gunkid
what is it you plan on doing I don't
know I do what I have to do the
consequence okay that's cool
alright there's more I don't know if
there's gonna be as stealthy secretiy
scary
no no oh
Jose Oh mmm the zoo what is what is
curry Yami mode what is that
curry ami mode what is that it sounds
Japanese but I don't know what it is
total numbers death eat not bad not bad
I guess all right I'm gonna find out
what Kure Yami mode is because I got a
little more time on this episode I
wonder if it's gonna be fun and
interesting luring enemies with your
voice yeah it's a important skill I know
I know it is okay
wait no yeah I remember now okay
so I do this query Yami stem in complete
darkness really holy crap that would be
nearly impossible I have to see what
that's like I have to see what it's like
don't turn the light out on me whoa okay
they were not joking about this being
dark holy crap that is pitch black
whoa that's so cool and so creepy I wish
I could have played it this way the
first time oh I cannot see a damn thing
I know I got to go around there we go
okay oh that's so weird oh that's so
weird I would love to have play this way
the first time
oh why did they save this for a new game
plus mode now I know what's coming this
could have been so much scarier oh I
would have loved this I don't know it's
so much creepier it would have been
great to do this off the bat oh man why
do they hold back what's so scary that's
so creepy oh it's so creepy so creepy
this is perfect why he why did they miss
this golden opportunity okay obviously
I'm not gonna play much more this has
been the assignment I'm gonna move right
on to the consequence and if it is as
scary as this one was I am going to be
very excited but I have a feeling there
might be just a little bit of combat in
it just to uh because I know that the
game oh whoa hey what the light no that
makes more sense that he's afraid of the
light that makes so much more sense ooh
I want to see sexy legs how's it going
oh boy come on come on come on come on
come on get in there get in there
I know this is gonna fixing yeah I would
have been so much better with the
spotlights sexy legs
it would have been so much creepier
because that thing has a spotlight on
his head and that would have made it so
much more senses everything was
absolutely pitch black oh they missed
out on so much here ah would have been
so cool with in so cool okay
sitting the way I'm all done with the
assignment but I'm gonna roll right on
to the consequence I really hope you
enjoyed this series I can't wait to do
more with the consequence and finally
the executioner at the end I have no
idea what that's gonna be like but we
shall see thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video alright your
makeups a little [ __ ] up but hey I'm
sure we can find something that doesn't
appreciate lips
you